good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
hospitals in india are continuing to
turn away patients as covid19 spreads
across the country
the country has seen a record number of
new cases for the fourth day running
the united states says it's offered help
after nearly one
million people tested positive in just
three days
hospitals are overwhelmed and makeshift
crematoria are being set up as cities
struggle to cope
in a moment we'll report from new delhi
on the growing crisis
well india's health ministry has just
released the country's latest
coronavirus figures
with a record number of new cases for a
fourth day running
the country saw 349 691 confirmed cases
between saturday and sunday bringing the
total to nearly 17 million
2 767 people have died in the last
24 hours making the official death toll
192
311. a warning this report from our
special correspondent alex crawford
starts on pictures of body bags
at a makeshift crematorium and contains
distressing images
throughout
there are too many dead to cope with
right now in parts of the indian capital
and they're piled up in vehicles outside
the coronavirus rules mean this is where
most relatives have to say goodbye
it's massively distressing and hugely
undignified
there's no room left inside the
crematorium so they've spilled out into
the open ground next door
coronavirus has ripped through this city
and they're rushing to keep up with the
devastation it's caused
so those with sick relatives are doing
everything they can to keep them alive
queuing up to fill up their own oxygen
cylinders
these are like gold dust in this city
with a black market value of four times
their normal price
so whatever that i asked i'll pay for it
so i have no clue
how much amount he is going to have so
when my number is going to come when my
chance is gonna come whatever amount if
this would happen like last year then it
would have been okay nobody knew about
it
but they got a year and they wasted it
completely on election rallies and all
the other stuff
so it's heartbreaking but uh we don't
have any other options
some of these people have been lining up
for hours but they are getting access to
oxygen
and they're asking if they can get hold
of it how come the government
and the hospitals can't
[Music]
a sports stadium opened only days ago as
a coveted facility because of the
shortage of beds in the city
was turning away patients today
but you've only got 50 people in there i
understand
it's the same story across much of the
capital with several of the top
hospitals still reporting
an acute shortage of oxygen and the
prime minister calling top-level
meetings to try to solve the crisis
why aren't you admitting any people why
have you got no oxygen beds available
not enough oxygen that didn't stop hina
from begging them to admit her father
he's a rickshaw driver and suffering
he's also the only earner in his family
and they've spent three months wages
buying an oxygen tank from an illegal
market
so he can breathe rich or poor
indians are doing whatever they can to
keep breathing
every section of society's been hit with
the deaths rising at their fastest rate
since the start of the pandemic
and cutting across every creed and
religion
but there's doubt about almost
everything with warnings that the surge
in testing
is now leading to a lack of testing
material
irfan is burying his brother but with a
death certificate
he doesn't believe 20 members my family
no positivity and as a covert victim
that means the precious muslim rituals
are also banned
and their heartache is all the more
because of what feels like gross
insensitivity and a keen sense that all
this could have been avoided
the country i am feeling very bad i have
money i have everything but i can't save
my sister
because no bed nothing nothing like that
no gas
no oxygen no bed where we can do where
we can go
all across the city and across the
country coronavirus
is leaving its scars on the land and on
its people
and india is now the global center of
this pandemic
just as it's waning in many other
countries
alex crawford sky news new delhi
let's take a look at the latest
coronavirus figures for the uk
there have been 2061 new cases of
coronavirus while 32 more deaths
have been reported which means the total
number of people who've died within 28
days of testing positive
is now 127 427.
on the vaccine rollout another 119
953 people have received their first
dose
while 448 139
received their second in total more than
45 and a half
million jabs have now been given out
across the uk
and there'll be more on the coronavirus
pandemic in today's edition of
sophie ridge on sunday amongst the
interviewees says bill gates
a prominent voice throughout the
pandemic also on the programme the
international trade secretary liz trust
and the labour mp jess phillips that's
all coming up at half past eight this
morning with jane secker
also this morning labour is demanding
the prime minister clarifies whether he
asked conservative supporters to help
pay for the refurbishment of a flat in
downing street
it follows claimed by his former adviser
dominic cummings who said mr johnson
had been planning what he called an
unethical foolish
possibly illegal plan downing street
says the prime minister paid for work
out of his own pocket a warning this
report from our political correspondent
joe pike begins with some
flash photography when he left
many in number 10 hoped the dominic
cummings drama was over
but it may just be getting started
cheers cheers labor and the snp are now
calling for an inquiry into these
revelations
every day there's more evidence of this
it is contemptuous and frankly this
attempt by the prime minister to say
nothing to see here nobody should be
bothered with what we're doing is also
contemptuous
the stench of sleaze that is surrounding
this uk tory government now is becoming
quite overpowering there are some very
serious allegations being leveled at
boris johnson by somebody who was very
very close to him
but boris johnson argues the public
aren't interested
do you have any response to that comment
from him he was a close political
colleague
my response is the one i'm giving which
is that it was the right thing
to to procure those ventilators and to
have that interaction
with dyson in the way that we in the way
that we did but did i think
do you think he was the source i would
do this i think he was the source of
that league
i i i don't think people care what they
care about is
uh that's not really an answer was what
was i doing back in march of last year
and people have people have attacked me
for that but did you did you finger him
as the source of that league
i don't think people give her monkeys to
be frank among the barrage of claims mr
cummings has entered the row over how
boris johnson
and his partner carrie simons spent tens
of thousands of pounds
on lavish renovations of their downing
street flat inspired
by designer lulu little then tried to
get a tory donor to secretly pay for it
mr cummings wrote i told him i thought
his plans to have donors secretly pay
for the renovation were unethical
foolish possibly illegal and almost
certainly broke the rules
mr johnson has now paid the bill himself
number 10 say he stuck to the rules
mr cummings also suggests civil servants
believed this man tory advisor henry
newman
leaked details of england's second
covert lockdown to the media
but boris johnson considered cancelling
the investigation into that leak
because mr newman is a close friend of
carrie simons
if you talk to people here they are
worried worried about what dominic
cummings knows
and worried about what he may reveal
next there is also speculation
in two of today's newspapers that mr
cummings at some point may make
a direct link between the prime
minister's handling of the coveted
pandemic
and the very high uk death toll so far
from opinion polls there is absolutely
no sign
the prime minister or his party standing
has been hit
but the longer this carries on the
greater chance that
may happen boris johnson says people
don't give a monkeys about all this
but in barnard castle the town famously
visited by dominic cummings
it seems some do yeah yeah i give him
monkeys
i like boris i think he's done a
fantastic job
you know things that go on they don't
they think the public don't care what
they do
i've just got the report and purpose
through and i will definitely be giving
it a
a great deal of thought this time depart
for health was
just a smoking ruin dominic cummings
will be back giving evidence to
parliament next month
it's likely to be another explosive
intervention from the man
some now call nuclear dom joe pike
sky news westminster
as part of the campaign to urge the
under 50s to get the coronavirus vaccine
a series of photographs documenting the
national vaccination program
have been released one of the
journalists who took
the pictures is jude palmer who joins me
now good morning
to you what was the uh brief that that
you were given what were you asked
to capture specifically good morning
yes i mean i think what we wanted to do
was we sort of see the stats every day
of how many people are getting
vaccinated
and i think we wanted to bring those
sort of to life really and bring that
bring all of those figures that we see
every day to life through the human
stories
and to really sort of capture the scope
of the human endeavor that's going on
in terms of the vaccine roll out um the
collaboration
the working together and the spirit
really that's around it
uh particularly the organization yeah
we're seeing some of the the images
now and uh some of the the sites for uh
vaccination more than 2800
um centers and you were
asked to to shoot in in salisbury
yes um so we've been shooting all over i
mean there's a team of us as we say
we've got
um we're covering the four nations so
we've got glenn edwards
in wales we've got liam mcburney
northern ireland myself covering england
and we'll have somebody in scotland
shortly um so i've been covering the
breadth of england
and going to all kinds of different
places from soft play areas to squash
courts
to salisbury cathedral and that was just
amazing really solsby cathedral because
the whole cathedral was turned into
a vaccination center and um they were
actually playing organ music as you went
into cathedral to have your vaccination
and
i spoke to the musical director and said
why were they doing that because
it was quite a powerful experience when
you walk into this amazing beautiful
cathedral
and everybody's walking in to be
protected
and so whether you're religious or not
it gave you a very sort of spiritual
feeling
um and he said it was to make people
feel at ease and to reassure people and
it definitely did that and it was just a
very
poignant moment i think yeah we were
seeing uh images of that quite
atmospheric
and uh interesting that that thought was
put into
you know what people might be feeling as
they go to get their their first uh
vaccination yeah i think you know we all
have our own individual stories about
how we've dealt with the pandemic
and how we deal with the vaccine and you
know everyone i speak to they have their
own journey with that
and when you sit in that chair to get
your vaccination it means different
things
to different people um but at the end of
the day
the overwhelming sense was of relief um
and just i'm just relieved to have it
done um and happiness really because it
moves us all a step further
to something that resembles normality
and were people um happy willing to be
photographed did you find
yes a lot were because a lot a lot of
people wanted to
help persuade other people to have the
vaccines so um
there was a lot of people that said yes
i'll do anything to help um and you know
this goes from all of the people that
were involved from when you arrive in
the car
park to um all the volunteers or the
marshals
all the way through the whole system
there's a sense of
the human endeavor that this is and the
spirit around it and people willing to
wanting to do their best for everybody
really and and
you know that was really the
overwhelming feeling um
so yes most people some people didn't
some people wanted it to be
you know their own private journey but
many people were willing to help
are there any particular images that
that struck you as the photographer
anything that remains with you um
there was there was a there was the
salisbury was one there was another of
we
um we had we i was photographing a
vaccination bus because if there's some
areas that have
a low uptake i was in the middle of
leeds and they have a vaccination bus
that
actually goes into those communities and
a lady and her husband walked around the
corner
and she was from somalia and she walked
around the corner and she came
onto the vaccination bus to get vaccine
she was she was quite nervous quite
anxious about having it done
and there's actually an image of her
there as i'm speaking um but she went
ahead she got the vaccine and when she
came out i chatted to her and her
husband
and her their son was actually a
tropical disease doctor in somalia
and she said now we can phone our son
and tell him that we've been vaccinated
and she was really
happy about that so i think that was a
big moment as well because she wasn't
expected to get vaccinated and as she
walked around the corner
the vaccination bus was there so it was
brilliant
and what sort of impact has it had on
you because nice to be able to
be uh taking photographs of essentially
a good news story
yeah i mean i think through what we've
all been through i think if you can take
any positives you need to take them
um and i think that this is a massive
thing in a historical thing so
as a photojournalist you know you want
to bear witness to these
these events but you have to be a little
bit more than that in this you have to
engage a little bit more
and i've you know because you have to
talk to people you have to
um find where the centers are you have
you know there's a lot of work involved
in doing it and i think that
to be part of history in this way as a
photojournalist is a big thing but also
as a human and
you know i've got children and and we've
all got family and friends and stuff
that you care about so
to be part of something that's so
important in our lives
um has been very well it's been very
memorable it will stay with me forever
this project
indeed very arresting images there thank
you so much for speaking to us sir jude
palmer footage's journalist thank you
27 people are reported to have died
after a fire at a hospital in iraq
it's claimed the blaze started after an
oxygen cylinder exploded inside the
building which was treating coronavirus
patients
at least 46 others are reported to have
been injured
in the last hour we've heard from the
indonesian president on the search for a
missing
submarine he said the navy has now
confirmed that the vessel has sunk
53 crew were on board when it was went
missing off the coast of bali on
wednesday
the search for the submarine is
continuing
the bbc's princess diana interview 1995
was arguably one of the biggest scoops
in
broadcasting history and earned the
journalist martin beshear a bafta
but that success has been tarnished with
new claims that he faked documents to
secure the interview
sky news has now seen internal bbc memos
which form part of the inquiry
they suggest the corporation was more
concerned about punishing whistleblowers
than investigating whether the documents
had been falsified
our royal correspondent random mills
reports
for 25 years they were kept within the
bbc
documents seen by sky news now part of
the inquiry into how panorama secured
that interview with princess diana
in 1995. they include press office logs
from around the time it was aired
that show claims martin beshear may have
told diana she was being spied on
chris blackhurst is one of those
mentioned he was tipped off by a source
while working at the independent i made
the first call
to them saying that he'd been looking
into
mi5 and he somehow
uh she'd been encouraged even pressured
it was probably too strong but
encouraged to give an interview
on the back of this and there was
definitely a cover-up and the bbc were
constantly pushing me back
an interview with the princess was the
ultimate scoop
martin beshear a relatively unknown
reporter a surprising choice
but the documents appeared to show
inconsistencies about how he met
diana tony hall was managing director of
news and current affairs at the time
and later became director general of the
bbc
in a statement the board of governors he
says diana's brother earl spencer
introduced martin to the princess of
wales but a document from
april 1996 says there had been no
intermediary
sources close to the princess have told
me they would never have met
without lord spencer who last year
called for the inquiry into what the bbc
knew
about bashir faking documents
it's only now 25 years after that
interview was aired that we're really
getting a sense of how little people on
the
outside knew about the investigations
that were going on
within the bbc so you can see from this
first document a journalist
asked if martin beshear had been
officially disciplined
the reply that he got from the press
office was that he had not
there's also this further document which
is a statement that
tony hall had written to the board of
governors in which he explains what's
been going on and it says
i've talked to martin martin beshear at
length about his reasons for compiling
the graphic
it says he has none other than he wasn't
thinking
i believe he is even with his laps
honest and an
honorable man he is contrite but a
further paragraph at the end
highlights just how much emphasis there
was on dealing with those who'd
leaked material to the press it says
here
we're taking steps to ensure the graphic
designer involved
matthew wiesler will not work for the
bbc again
in addition it says we will work to deal
with the leakers
and remove persistent troublemakers from
the program
we've been told matt wiesler only found
out last year
about his apparent blacklisting we
approached martin beshear and lord
hall for comment and we're told by the
bbc
the bbc is determined to get to the
truth about the circumstances
and has commissioned lord dyson to carry
out a fully independent investigation
martin beshear is cooperating fully and
won't be making
any public statements while the
investigation is ongoing
it's understood lord dyson a former
judge is
on track to report back next month those
closest to diana hoping for some degree
of clarity
even with the most important witness no
longer alive
rihanna mills sky news
when greta thundberg decided to sit
outside the swedish parliament for three
weeks in 2018 demanding climate action
she couldn't have known the
extraordinary impact her activism would
have around the world
now the climate change movement in many
countries is increasingly being led by
young people
from the uk to australia north america
and uganda
sky news has spoken to some of the young
people leading the debate
correspondent ashna haranak reports
a generation fighting for their futures
determined to not let their lives be
crippled by climate change
this is now the soundtrack of school
curriculums too
people aren't taking that action and
aren't realising
what they need to do and i think as a
generation we're doing really well with
sort of
taking that emotion and using it in
order to take action
because we know it's our generation
they're going to be impacted by it and
as us
are going to be affected by it it's
really important that we make that
change
emma is one of the uk's first climate
change teachers and says the appetite
for making a difference
is infectious giving them that that
perseverance and that determination to
go i'm not going to let us go
i'm not going to let this go i'm going
to keep fighting for it but in a polite
way
across the world the climate voices are
getting louder and
younger sixteen-year-old anjali is
taking the australian government to
court over a new coal mine
she says the burden of responsibility
weighs heavy on young
shoulders i think that while it is
really empowering you know like i
come home sometimes at the end of a long
day of um you know a school strike
meeting
or um you know the end of the press
conference and i feel really
accomplished but then it's also kind of
bittersweet because it's like
it sucks that i have to take my future
into my own hands from the front line of
the climate crisis in uganda
activist vanessa says many are
disconnected from what they can't see
there are communities that are being
affected right now
they're communities whose bots are
sinking
faster or burning faster but in the end
of it
all if nothing is done about this then
everybody is going to catch fire
then every boat is going to drown
kevin is demanding cleaner air for
americans he says he's vocal about
demanding change because he
cares young people are really making the
connections between women's rights
civil rights and environmentalism and
climate change that's the reason why
young people are so heavily involved
is because we want to grow up in a world
where we don't have to be played by
these injustices these disparities and
inequalities
as leaders of the future their passion
is driving the climate movement
a generation of trailblazers determined
not to be drowned out
ashnaharanag sky news
and our new daily climate show will be
back from tomorrow that's at half past
six and a half past nine
in the evening here on sky news
now for a look at the weather with
isabelle and it's uh
still lovely but not as lovely as
yesterday and just the temperatures and
just the way it feels i suppose but i
mean it's going to look
gorgeous i mean the sunshine is stunning
uh just a little bit of fair weather
cloud around it's just
quite a cool breeze and it'll be more
widespread i think that northeasterly
today so more of us seeing a knock-on
effect on the temperature let's take a
look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so we've got high pressure in charge
which is keeping the weather fine and
dry but around the high
it's quite breezy quite gusty actually
across the southwest
and that wind coming in from a cool east
or northeasterly direction
bringing in a little bit of fair weather
cloud to parts of eastern england and
temperatures on the coast they're
struggling actually north sea of course
at this time of year so
some places only 9 to 11 degrees but
come in land probably around say 13 for
the midlands and southeast england and
then around 15 16 for west wales a
little down on yesterday's
the west of ireland 17 or 18 parts of
northern scotland again up to about the
17 celsius mark not bad strong sunshine
remember wherever you are
and then as we head through this evening
and tonight the winds ease in the
south it'll be chilly again with a touch
of frost not a bad start to the week
though in southern britain and ireland
but the north
will see changes with some rain heading
in
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
you're watching sky news breakfast
coming up after the break we'll take a
look at what's making the front pages of
the newspapers with the editor of the
sunday express michael booker
do stay with us it's a fine and sunny
sunday thanks to high pressure but it's
still windy across the far
south and cool north easterly winds will
bring in more cloud to eastern parts
through the course of the day
temperatures only 11 on the east coast
but further west maybe up to 17 or 18
celsius quite strong sunshine mind you
and then after frost tonight we will see
some changes tomorrow with rain heading
in
from the north in terms of air pollution
today it's
mostly low but there will be some
pockets of moderate pollution
especially around the western isles and
western scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
joining me now to take us through the
newspapers as the editor of the sunday
express michael booker good morning to
you again
uh let's start with the times uh
and this piece likening the split
between uh boris johnson and dominic
cummings to a civil war
yeah they always like to get macho and
civil wary and there's also mention of
it being like the mafia in there as well
uh but when it's just you know lots of
uh
looking politicians middle class men
bickering is what it really is but they
always like to make it look dramatic
and uh it's tim shipman uh in the sunday
times right in this piece and he is
well plugged in and has been uh similar
to both camps both the cummings and
boris johnson's camps
over the years and it's just interesting
because you know when dominic cummings
uh the uh
prime minister's a former chief advisor
came out with his blog post
on friday uh joining in and uh answering
his critics in some cases and
uh making allegations against the prime
minister and
denying he'd been leaking some of these
stories that had been coming out
recently
i think a lot of people expected the
sunday newspapers to have some huge
bombshell that could ultimately
take down the prime minister but nothing
so far it just seems to be
a lot of bluster a lot of long written
pieces for white hall insiders there's
some good detail in this
talking about how this is a civil war
and what it is
is that we had the vault leave family of
which dominic cummings and boris johnson
were
key members of and then he's got boris
johnson's real family which is carrie
simmons at the head of it
uh his fiancee and it seems as time has
gone on
the botting between the uh the two sides
of heads
uh between the two sides has got too
much
there was that split in december last
year and this has been festering ever
since and uh
dominic cummings still thinks he can win
the war
according to this piece but so does
boris johnson and ultimately
according to tim shipman it could bring
them both down uh
so it is fairly dramatic stuff it also
there's a great line in it that says
that uh dominic cummings is the sort of
guy who brings nuclear weapons to a
pillow fight
so there's some good drama in it indeed
uh take us to the
the mail and what's the story about um
baroness boothroyd being
investigated over missing a sexual
harassment course as the former
speaker yeah well a pioneer for women
and women's rights and you're the first
women
well only woman uh speaker so far we've
got a deputy woman speaker at the moment
but yeah
she was a pioneer but she's currently
been investigated by the commons uh
watchdog because
she hasn't done an online training
course in sexual harassment or
how to avoid it and how to combat it um
now she has a very good excuse because
she's had open heart surgery
she's told them this and they're still
investigating her anyway
now it's this sort of thing because
clearly we want to stamp out sexual
harassment in the workplace and
everywhere and people need to be aware
of it
people need to do these courses but when
someone has an excuse like this she's a
91 year old pioneer
she is ill at the moment she says look i
want to take this course you can always
learn new things but
i'm slightly indisposed at the moment
but they're still going to go on with
this investigation and i think that's
where people
um raise their eyebrows that these sort
of pushes
towards the education of people
in these matters because it seems to be
it does seem to be just for the sake of
it and box ticking
rather than getting someone to do it
when they're fit and healthy
and and can do it properly yeah
hopefully it's just an admin
error and that will be corrected
to the times um and this is about
um well also about uh sexism and uh a
primary school
banning certain sexist welcome what they
consider to be sexist phrases and words
yeah well it's like they've taught the
kids to be sort of like the the police
in the school for what teachers say
which i think again may raise eyebrows
with certain people particularly some
parents uh who are probably more
traditional in these ways and think
teachers should be in charge rather than
the pupils but
the kids have been given these little
signs and particularly the girls and if
anyone accidentally says come on guys
let's get going the girls will then pick
up a sign and says
i'm not a guy with an exclamation mark
and the teachers are then felt told off
also in this school which is anderson
park
primary school in birmingham the kids
have been
if they hear something untoward from say
a supervisor
in the playground and on one occasion
one of the supervisors said to a boy
boys don't skip and took a skipping rope
on it
two girls ran to the head teacher told
on the supervisor
the supervisor got a telling off funnily
enough the supervisors no longer decided
to work for the school anymore so uh yes
these
the we've got a tiny little police force
running around obviously uh
clearly we should again we should stamp
out sexism and stamp out an early age
but it does seem to be putting a bit of
a responsibility on kids
yes indeed uh the telegraph to round up
um hackers the fear of hackers uh
crashing
the oscars party this year not not
normally sort of the uh the people on
the red carpet trying to get in that way
but but
on the internet that's what they're
worried about well apparently yes i mean
the the oscars night tonight
there's going to be some online parties
where you can go to a virtual party with
elton john if you pay
a few hundred thousand pounds for the
pleasure and he will virtually turn up
at your table
and speak to you with david furnish for
a while now i'm not sure how
not what an online hacker would do to
get into this party and if you can
i don't know i've never had an online
vollevant or an online
glass of champagne but apparently it's
worth a while for these hackers to do
that but
i don't know i think sometimes hackers
just do this for the sake of it i think
we should just leave the lobbies to
themselves in their virtual lovely world
i'm still waiting for my online
invitation as i'm sure you are michael
thanks for taking us through the papers
good to see you thank you